hey how's it going everyone Clinton
Jones here with another tutorial on how
I did the signs video so you guys said
that you wanted a tutorial so I'll do
one and super 886 suggested that I do a
tutorial for every video you know worth
having a tutorial for so if you guys
would like me to do that let me know and
I'll do it because I think it's a pretty
cool idea alright so let's go over this
footage here we'll start with the
original of course and basically what I
did was I mean pump this down bit is you
know it's moving shot right before you
know get on the freeway so what I did
was motion track this first thing I did
was motion track and you want to go in
here track motion rotation because the
camera is rotating and you would check
scale if you're zooming in and out but
what you would do is go in here and get
some tracking points here you want to
get high contrast areas so these black
and white corners are perfect because
it's easy for you know the program to
stick to that so what you would do to
make up to do a better track is scale
this up and bring this in again what
this is going to do it's gonna make a
little slower but it's going to be a
much more accurate you know better track
so when I track forward you know those
are going to stick there and you're
gonna have to monitor these because you
know whether you film on a high frame
rate there's gonna be blurry or you know
maybe you're moving too much so you need
to watch these and kind of adjust them
manually sometimes for me it's probably
all the time because I'm terrible at
motion tracking it takes forever so what
you do is you would make a layer new
null object you would edit your target
set it to your null object and you would
hit apply hit okay and you would bring
it up here it's gonna undo all that
though okay so once we have it tracked
this whole footage once we have the
whole all the footage tracked what you
want to do is go to
just any point in time like right here
most like pretty much when it's like
when there's no blur when it's pretty
crisp and we're going to save this frame
we're gonna save this frame right here
go to composition save frame as file
just save it as a Photoshop layer and
we're gonna open this up in Photoshop
now what you're gonna do in Photoshop is
use the clone stamp tool to you know
take pieces you know from here and just
kind of paint it over and eventually
just make a paint out this 575 here and
you want to take this and paint out all
this stuff and get this Georgia 5 out of
here same for this the red paint out the
interstate so you want to keep building
it up keep layering until you paint all
this stuff out one thing to keep in mind
don't just paint out this 5 and the 7
and the 5 you know make a whole layer
that goes from here and it cuts off here
make this whole thing blue that way when
you bring it back into After Effects and
you and you motion track it and add the
blur it's not going to kind of you know
if it's if it's just the 5 7 in the 5
and it doesn't go all the way out to
here and you had motion blur you're
gonna see it underneath so with that in
mind we are going to turn on some of
these layers and you'll see that if I
saw that it's just this whole piece turn
on all these and you see we have these
blank signs then and stump still in
Photoshop here my added back in some
picture so I took in another Facebook
sign then I took the Twitter sign I
finally got a Twitter so if you want to
follow me if you have any interest in
follow me on Twitter this is it right
here
then I added my face in here commissure
YouTube broadcast yourself
so one thing to keep in mind when you're
doing this this white it's not perfectly
white
it matches this white right here and
this black is not perfectly black it's
kind of gray they match each other you
want to match a black and whites that
way when you're compositing it's gonna
look you know realistic that's another
step you can take and making it look
realistic is matching your blacks and
whites alright so once you have that
finished in Photoshop and they're all on
their own layers as you can see here
they're all they're all their own layers
you're going to want to go to file
import file and when you open a
Photoshop file it's gonna bring up this
box here you want to choose editable
layer styles hit OK and you're gonna get
something like this you can see all my
layers here what do you want to do is
just copy and paste all of these ctrl-c
ctrl-v into this comp hopefully your
markers should still be on the frame
that you saved out if you wanted to you
can hit control one or not control shift
shift one and make a little marker there
so that you can go back to the frame
paste it here so it's like perfectly
aligned select all your layers and pick
with them pick whip them to the null or
parent them to the null and turn on
motion blur and make sure you turn this
on too because if it's not then it won't
work so once we have all that of the way
it should stick pretty well just like
that alright so let's talk about another
shot another technique this is kind of
this is cheating here so I mean it looks
good but I consider cheating so this is
not footage this is actually just a
picture what I did was I filmed this you
know and I tracked it but the track
wasn't it wasn't perfect if you ever
have something to where the track just
isn't perfect or you know it looks kind
of crappy what you want to do is you
want to you know track it keep the track
apply it to your null and then bring in
a picture that's fairly large because if
they're zooming in you don't want to
scale it up and lose quality you'd
rather scale it down
and maintain quality so this is a very
big picture it's like 5000 pixels buy
something and take that picture and
parent it to your Knoll
now if I didn't parent it it would just
look you know well if you took all this
stuff out it would look normal
this is a picture but as soon as I
parent it it's gonna start moving around
with stuff now this is the original and
all I did was I brought this into
Photoshop same thing same deal brought
it into Photoshop you know started you
know masking away until I got this here
and you know this is Brett's movie up
here and then pretty long right here so
all I did was you know I did that I
saved it out as the Photoshop file and I
copied and pasted these pictures into
this composition and it's gonna be
perfectly stuck to this billboard here
because it's just a picture so when you
move it it's just it's gonna look
perfect I actually used this in the
fallout video when you know I walked up
and there's all those guys with blood
all over them with a gas mask guys I
couldn't track it it was too hard it my
camera was too it was too pixelated at
the time I just didn't look good so what
I do is I kept the track and I and I
applied the picture to the track and you
know it it looks perfect so that's just
a cool little tip you guys can use so
yeah let me know if you guys want any
more tutorials I'll be coming out with
two really awesome videos within the
next week and a half I'm filming them
with Brett this guy up here he's coming
over actually in a couple hours so we're
gonna film some really cool stuff for
you guys yeah in the meantime why don't
you guys try some your own motion
tracking and send me your shots let me
know I'll see you guys later